this video is brought to you by
manscaped okay so the boys season 3
episode 5 is now out and this legendary
entry is packed with easter eggs hidden
details and callbacks to the comics we
last left the boys in russia after they
freed soulja boy from the clutches of
his captors after this episode i think
it's pretty clear he's gonna superman
that homelander and possibly team up
with the boys to take down the big bad
in the show we're gonna be breaking it
all down but full spoilers ahead so if
you haven't had a chance to check it out
then i highly recommend you check out
now yes i'm laughing at how bad my jokes
are but we're gonna be going in deep and
if you've enjoyed the video so far then
please hit the thumbs up button much
appreciated as always and thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
boys now last week we talked about how
the russian plot plays on the once
started in issue 11 of the source
material though it diverted heavily from
the comics and the mission to kill
little nina it did end up dovetailing
into the story of the legend who
explained the history of war to huey in
the show he's played by paul reiser who
you might recognize from stranger things
and for being that damn punk carter
burke in the movie aliens damn chump now
the show changes things up slightly from
the comics and in those he was a stanley
parody that wrote an illustrated comics
for the soups this was a big pr move by
the company to make them look like the
good guys whereas here he's the ex-vp of
vort who was in charge of hero
management because he's produced so many
movies i'm wondering if he's meant to be
the kevin feige of this world but let me
know below exactly what you think now in
the comics we learned why he was helping
the boys and he detailed the history of
war to huey after he killed the bloney
[ __ ] he said that they'd been trying to
get into the arms race for decades and
during the second world war they built
planes for the army they massively
undercut all the other contractors so
they got major amounts of money from the
government but their planes
malfunctioned a lot and often ended up
killing the pilots they then turned
their hand to creating rifles and during
one of the big skirmishes an entire
platoon that used them was wiped out
because they wouldn't fire the soldiers
ended up having their heads impaled on
rifles which the legend said showed the
rifles had at least one use for them now
after this have all ended up trying to
push their suits into the military but
as we've seen they're highly defective
due to their personality disorders the
comics actually had votes planned in the
white house vic the veep stop the army
from interfering with 911 and this is
where the seven went in the show had the
plain crash scene play out but in the
comics it's way more [ __ ] up with the
seven actually causing it to crash in in
the brooklyn bridge killing thousands
there and everyone on board the legend
ended up supplying the boys with info on
the seven and we learn why this was in
the source material turns out that one
of his sons was part of the platoon that
got wiped out because of their rifles
and since then he's vowed to take down
the company he also discovered that his
other son was the bloney [ __ ] and the
reason he held off telling huey was
because he wanted him to kill him first
said he was a right
which is also touched upon in the show
when he says he hates his kids now we
start off watching a recording of the
russians experimenting on soulja boy
after his capture in nicaragua this
starts off on the 8th of july 1986 and
we can see from the timestamps that they
tortured him for several years
eric kripke and jensen ackles both work
together on the show supernatural and we
can also see the date january 24th which
is the birthday of the latter's
character dean winchester he also talked
about his high radiation levels and
though this wasn't shown in his entrance
last week the trailer actually changed
out the sound effects to add the
clicking that we typically get with a
geiger counter
soldier boy could well be the weapon
that's used to kill homelander and huge
shout outs to dr debunk on our last
video who theorized that soldier boy's
new abilities can actually take away
soup's powers similar to leech from
x-men eric crick he talked about this in
his entertainment weekly recaps and said
that radiation can wipe out the soup's
powers so it might be something in the
future that takes down homelander and
levels the playing field a bit more
these experiments are of course also
riffing on the winter soldier ones that
were carried out by hydra and bucky in
order for them to turn him into a weapon
mother's milk is watching this on an old
timely tv and his mirrors him last week
watching soldier boy on solid gold on a
similar sort of set you have the high
points and low points in his career
starting off both entries and it's sort
of like poetry they rhyme now soldier
boy killed a scientist experimenting on
him but he was gassed and then put on
ice i think that vote might try and spin
his return similar to captain america's
origin story and we already know they
made it look like he died sacrificing
himself so they could pick up on the
other side of this and make it appear
like he's been stuck in stasis for years
mother's milk figures out that billy
killed gunpowder and he says that no one
should have that power which is a
sentiment butcher later says to maeve
b-24 in the series very much makes the
characters that take it into addicts and
we've seen billy getting withdrawal
symptoms huey looking at his arm on a
high and in this entry we join him
vomiting you also get a quick flash of a
character that barely witnessed in a
vision who's labeled in the cast simply
as the teen originally he said what
would becca think of this and i think it
might be billy's brother lenny lenny
ended his own life because of the abuse
they both suffered at the hands of their
father and he was very much the person
that stopped billy from going too far
characters have also remarked that huey
is very much a felon fellaini as he's
the person who holds butcher back from
becoming the monster inside of him we'll
talk about this later on in the video as
i want to go over what happens to
butcher in the comics and how this
episode is teasing towards it i'll give
you a big spoiler warning before we go
into it though but it'll be at the end
of the video so stick around for that
now the boys is all about fatherly
relationships you've got homelander and
ryan mother's milk and janine stan edgar
and victoria newman and so on and so
forth that's why yeah bear with me we've
teamed up with manscape to bring you
their new performance package 4.0 just
in time for father's day i've been using
this stuff for over a year now and it's
made a massive difference when it comes
to trimming my boys so i'm bringing you
this amazing deal the 4th generation kit
comes with the brand new lawnmower 4.0
body trimmer that's completely
waterproof and it also has a 400k led so
it starlights your face as you shave it
this is their sleekest electrical
trimmer and it also has advanced skin
safe technology so you'll avoid all
those nasty nicks and curts that you
normally need your healing factor for
completely cordless it's got a super
smart charging system that will give you
power for 90 minutes so you don't have
to worry about it running out of juice
when you're shaving your soldier boy if
you're heading out somewhere to russia
like you're on a mission for little nina
you can also engage the travel lock
feature by clicking the main button
three times and this will stop the razer
from accidentally going off when you're
on the go on top of this the pack also
has two products i didn't even know i
needed until now and that is the crop
preserver ball deodorant and crop
revivable toner spray it's also another
two big items in it that have been a
complete life saver for me i've got a
i've got a bit of a big schnoz yeah i'll
i'll admit it got a spot on the front of
it as well which isn't too good at the
moment but
this weed whacker that they've got in it
it massively helps me to get rid of my
nose hairs very quickly and there's also
the boxes 2.0 as you know i've just
become a father myself so i'm starting
to go on a lot of long walks with the
pram like a prankster and the boxers 2.0
stop my legs from chaffing so i never
need to worry about that included in the
kit as well as a travel bag so whether
you get this for your father or for
yourself you can take it wherever you
want to go whenever you need to go get
20 off and free shipping with the code
heavy spoilers at manscape.com now
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com use the code heavy spoilers
and get this awesome gift for father's
day at manscape.com
cheers now we go to the vote board and
she actually has been appointed as the
ceo she goes to give a story about how
her mother died of cancer when she was
17 but homeland interrupts this takes
the main seat and ends up talking down
to the members after they ask him how
he's going to handle their margins going
down on the earnings call disney has
lots of earnings calls every year and
they are pretty sh but they tease
trailers at them so everyone watches
them they're basically big zoom calls
and the last one went down about as well
as tubin and the hanford parish council
one homelander clearly has no idea what
they're talking about so he just goes
she's just kicked him out
no she's coming don't don't just kicked
him out
read the standing orders read them and
understand them
anyway watch the handved parish council
video instead of this
a homelander is ousting all the people
in professional positions and swapping
them out with supes who have no idea
what's going on the major failing in 9
11 that the legend talked about was
because they were all morons who had no
idea how to de-escalate hostage
situations or actually land planes
because they're basically just
celebrities with no experience in
anything outside of standing and waving
at parades the deep ends are firing most
of the staff from war crime analytics
and we once more join anika who has
appeared in every season so far first
introduced to track down translucent she
was also put to work by black noir in
season 2. i believe that she's drinking
turbo rush when we first meet her and
later on she had some chocolates with
nuts in them in the second season black
noir ended up making her put these in
the bin because as we know he's allergic
to dem nuts what nuts these nuts now
cassandra has brought in some cupcakes
with you had me at sprinkles written in
the box and they also have crime
analytics with anal a anal spell out one
okay good one now kimiko is slowly
starting to heal and she's taken to the
hospital leaving just billy and huey
supersonic's death is blaine on a drug
overdose possibly riffing on the death
of marilyn monroe her death was ruled as
being through an overdose of
barbiturates however many have theorized
that she was actually murdered hughie
wears a hole in oats t-shirt and the
man-eater arrives in starlight she says
because he's used compound v he's out of
touch but they're out of time and he
offers her an almond joy which is what
anika eats later on in the episode these
chocolate bars actually also appeared in
season 2 when starlight and huey got
them from the vending machine so it's a
nice little romantic gesture carried out
by huey black noir is used to take maeve
down and it is possible that these bars
are getting dotted about to help when he
inevitably comes for either huey or
annie he's now homeland as weapon and as
we learned in episode 3 he did used to
be normal but the attack in nicaragua
severely scarred him and likely left him
brain damaged season 2 showed us that
edgar had complete control over him and
now that homeland has access to all the
things he did he fully controls the
character he's likely got reduced brain
functionality now and this explains why
he sits about drawing cats and also
can't talk in the comics he was way more
powerful and one of the big villains but
they've clearly changed things up here i
don't feel like i'm spoiling things as
the show is diverting from the comics
but if you don't want them ruined then
skip ahead about a minute in the video
because we're going to be talking big
black noir reveals now in the comics
black noir was a clone of homelander
that slowly sent him insane through
dressing up as him committing heinous
acts and then sending him photographs so
that he believed he'd blacked out whilst
carrying these acts out homelander
realized that he could get away with
this kind of stuff and then just got
worse and worse black nour had actually
been created to take homeland down if it
ever came to it and not being able to
carry out this mission sent him insane
so he slowly gaslet homelander until he
attacked the white house and it was at
this point that he was called in to
destroy him a black noir in the show
seems completely different but we know
from the boy's diabolical that he still
has the purpose of taking down
homelander if he goes rogue noir is not
there to teach you he is there to watch
you make sure you don't screw up and
embarrass the company and bring you in
if you do
huey talks about how compound v made him
feel like he was no longer weak and he
very much wants to save starlight for
one switch will likely push him into
using it again a soldier boy sneaks back
into the us and we catch billy getting a
visit from maeve who's brought compound
v24 with her at butch's request he's
very much addicted to it i think huey
being on it too has enabled him to get
more in season 2 mother's milk said that
huey was his canary but after he took it
it's allowed buchi to think it's fair
game butcher says he hates being on v
and i think this will be something that
drives him into going down the same dark
road that he does in the comics he also
says that all soups have to go and like
i said we'll talk about this more in
depth towards the end of the video we
get in on to the classic saying with
great power comes great responsibility
but billy switches it up to say that it
turns you into a right
maven butcher get it on and weirdly in
the comics she was hooking up with the
legend quite a lot working as his inside
man well well woman now we come to the
hospital and we catch little nina
threatening frenchie to work for her
once more she blows smoke in people's
faces who are on oxygen and just
completely ruins everyone's lives now
they stop at a poster with homelander on
it that says brave very much showing
that the supes infiltrate every aspect
of people's lives and even their deaths
little nina wants frenchie to kill a kid
and this very much reflects several of
the characters in the show
nina wants to use him as a weapon which
he doesn't want to be but he used kimiko
as one and victoria was also used by
eddie to propel vore to whatever ends he
wanted there's also soulja boy at the
end who butcher makes a pact with and it
becomes very clear that he's just using
him as a weapon too her kimiko is
actually over the moon that she can't
heal and she struggles to lift hospital
equipment meaning that she's finally out
of the life however i think she'll get
injected with b once more and will be
forced back into this when she hears
frenchie is in danger in the comics
little nina was actually killed in
russia so they are diverting quite
heavily from that now we cut to
starlight confronting a train who denies
snitching on super sonic but in ashley's
office we get to confirm that he did a
train is obviously on his way out due to
his inability to use his powers and thus
he's been trying whatever he can to keep
himself relevant this led him into the
turbo rush ad snitching on super sonic
and it later makes him want to work
alongside a racist soup so that they can
create some positive pr inside ashley's
office she gets a bouquet from senator
lindsey graham and similar to edgar
she's dipping her toes into politics to
benefit the company later on when
starlight goes to see her her office is
completely filled with flowers showing
how many have reached out to her to try
and get in good favor with the company
in the comics her character was actually
set up as a patsy and with edgar being
out the way when everything blows up the
blame could definitely end up falling at
her feet blue hawk gets called in and
he's very much a metaphor for police
brutality in the press material we see
that he carries a trench in and he beats
up a train's brother so badly that he'll
likely never walk again we then go to
soldier boy returning to new york like
captain america he's a man out of time
whereas cap was accepting of the modern
world soldier boy has the same views as
your granddad who you have to keep
telling off a christmas dinner you know
the guy constantly saying bad stuff now
he walks past the poster robert singer
and we know that he's a veteran due to
his campaign video soldier boy seemingly
recognizes him and it's even possible
that the parent counted each other at
one point in the comics singer or rather
dakota bob is the president and it's
likely that his campaign trail will lead
to this with victoria becoming his vp
like a comic book counterpart he ends up
detonating in the street and this seems
like it's aping the civil war comic run
in which his super villain also did the
same thing in the marvel universe this
led to the superhuman registration act
and it's going to be interesting to see
if this leads into soups being
restricted homelander is still getting a
lot of praise on the vort news network
and we occur to janine watching a report
of him mother's milk arrives and he's
angered by this likely because it
reflects his own childhood milk
remembers watching soldier boy with his
father and grandfather and he was
completely enamored by his appearance on
solid gold however as we learned this
was all an act angeline seems to be
falling for the same thing in the same
circumstances as he did milk is wearing
a stop the violence t-shirt and this is
a nod to the sung and movement by krs-1
milk is annoyed that todd is spouting
off all its raw propaganda and he's also
a teacher meaning that he not only has
influence over jeanine but also the kids
in his class the rest of the entry kind
of centers around soldier boy with huey
and butcher venturing to the attack site
here they meet mother's milk and we also
see huey is wearing a this is a t-shirt
a nod to the michael jackson tour a
train and blue hawk go to the community
center to try and put a spin on the
ladder's brutality but this ends up
escalating even further blue hawk says
he's not racist because he has friends
like atrain but as we know the pair only
met for the first time in the scene
before this there's some clear social
commentary here with slogans like black
lives matter all lives matter and soup's
lives matter being dropped a train very
much represents not only the black
community but also the soups community
too and after his brother nate gets
badly injured i think he's gonna have to
decide who he actually wants to stand
with a train has had a really
interesting arc throughout the series
and i think he's starting to see that
bad things happen when he refuses to act
he's currently trying to stay in there
with the supes but this has led to super
sonic's death his brother being injured
and if we're being honest homelander
doesn't care about him at all he's
someone who's appeared a mocker protest
for his drink turbo rush but i actually
think he's gonna have to pick a side now
and stop hiding behind the image we have
seen that vault completely disregard
black people and this was shown by the
fact that they wanted noir behind a mask
however they clearly brought blue hawk
in to do this as a pr stunt but it
massively backfired still low the spin
continues and blue hawk blames it on
antifa across town they meet the legend
who lives in the penthouse and his home
is adorned with several famous faces
this includes grace jones burt reynolds
carrie fisher steve mcqueen roy
schneider elizabeth taylor and a couple
i'm not sure on so let me know below if
you know who they are he has countless
hollywood stories namely one about
marlon brando giving him an offer he
couldn't refuse and he also jack the
drug joke from peep show
no thanks i'm full he also has a fake
leg and this is something that he takes
off similar to a scene in the comics in
which the legend does the same thing
they get on to how soldier boy doesn't
really age and he brings up bb kate who
you might know is starring in gremlins
drop dead fred and that scene from fast
times at ridgemont high you know you
know the scene i'm talking about now he
brings up how soldier boy was 63 and
they had a massive age difference which
he compares to michael sorry sean
connery and catherine zeta jones there's
also a mention of kelly lebrock and it's
clear that the guy has been around the
brock
now we discover he's handed over soldier
boy's costume to him along with the
address of chimps don't cry superstar
the crimson countess we see her poster
hanging up in the wide shot of the room
and she does go out with a bang
of the cameron coleman show and i want
to apologize for a mistake last week i
corrected myself for saying rocket
romance instead of pocket romance
however i said cameron coulson instead
of cameron coleman i let myself down i
let my parents down but most importantly
i'll let you guys down i see you i feel
you jump i grow now he brings up soldier
boy and also talks about stormfront's
followers the stormchasers on 4chan who
we first heard about last season
homelander has needy been the conspiracy
theory that this attack only happened
because edgar wants revenge in the
build-up to the show last year there was
talk about how there would be some
social commentary on the pandemic and
i'm wondering if this is what they were
referring to homelander says it's safe
to go to restaurants and movie theaters
even though the threat of soldier boy is
out there and though this might be a
reach i'm wondering if this is the part
that they were talking about he ends up
seeing maeve in the main seven office
and after he smells butcher on her he
realizes that she switched sights she
ends up telling him that when they were
together that she hated him and this is
reflected later on in crimson counties
who says the exact same thing to soldier
boy from the start
i hated you
i hated you
the pair were both in relationships for
the sake of pr and they end up falling
victim to the person that loved them for
homelander it's working with butcher and
for soldier boy it's her being part of
his takedown in nicaragua black noir is
unleashed on her and it is possible that
she'll be taken hostage in the comics
this was a room that both she and
homeland afford in and she ended up
trying to use her sword on him but it
didn't work because it was just a prop
last week we saw her training with the
same weapon and it is possible they'll
do a similar scene down the line we
learn that her disappearance has been
given a cover story and that she's
apparently at the global wellness
retreat ashley is terrified of
homelander and is happy to lie for him
but starlight is finally fully standing
up to him mother's milk refuses to take
compound b24 whereas huey signs up to it
straight away showing the addictive
qualities of it milk very much
represents someone who just says no and
butcher ends up ostracizing him later on
because of it now it's been a bit bit
doom and gloom hasn't it however we get
a really fun and upbeat scene with
kimiko and frenchie throughout the
season she's fantasized being in a
musical and after watching a clip of
judy garland she gets up and starts
dancing around the halls with frenchie
this is from the 1943 movie girl crazy
and the pair mime the song i got rhythm
really fun scene and we coded the
crimson countess who lives out in chimp
country a retreat for monkeys get a lot
of carol baskin's vibes from this and
she's currently working as a cam girl we
see sir comes a lot 779 who's played by
seth rogen in his second cameo in the
franchise rogan is a producer for the
boys and he also showed up in laser
baby's day out along with evan goldberg
this moment is interrupted by butcher
and they chain crimson counters up which
is probably what she had in mind anyway
now as we touched on earlier they handed
soldier boy over and now we don't find
the exact reason out it's clear he was
abusive and that vaude probably wanted
him taken down we know that they've been
using victoria as a way to legally
remove the supes that cause issues and
it might be a similar situation where
they wanted to get rid of him but didn't
know how to do it they of course created
the cover story for him and if it was
just the russians they would have likely
out and out said it rather than doing
what they did the file that maeve gave
to butcher actually had some hints
towards it and it said he'd been dealing
narcotics with la cosa nostra though
this was done with the cia he may have
been making money on the side and
potentially this is why they took him
out guessing we'll find out more later
on but that's the end of eerie time any
return
[Music]
now starlight drops in after being
called by mother's milk and huey shows
her his teleportation powers unlike
teddy stilwell he can't shift his
clothes yet but he might learn how to do
this later down the line but she betrays
her mother's milk mirroring the one by
maeve and crimson countess and he drugs
him so that soulja boy can go in the
ladders home butcher is very much
someone who views people as weapons and
he of course did this with kimiko he's
now also doing it with soldier boy and
appearing as an ally to him so that he
can help take homeland or out now i kind
of feel the design of soulja boy here is
meant to mirror captain america in
avengers infinity war in which he was
supposed to be based on his persona the
nomad soldier boy is of course heavily
parodying cap's design and him becoming
a criminal of course reflects soldier
boy status here they show that he
doesn't mind turning against those that
he views as being on the wrong side
mimicking the civil war storyline that
led to him going on the run soldier boy
kills the crimson countess and he walks
out the fire which is when huey stops
starlight from attacking him the enemy
of my enemy is my friend and they get
what you call a team up annie is
devastated and once more it carries the
idea of couples separating going forward
i think the three will try and attack
homelander to take him down but he'll be
too strong i honestly don't think
they'll stand a chance as he of course
has black noir at his disposal and
there's also the fact that huey isn't
trained it's basically gonna be
butchering soulja boy versus homelander
and maybe black noir which sounds like a
big battle there's no way to really
predict how this will go as it's not
part of the comics and in them there
were actually three versions of soldier
boy the first was about during the
second world war but he and the second
one were killed the third one was
homeland as love at one point and he was
a bit of a [ __ ] who also got killed as
well so really no way to guess how it's
gonna go but what i am sure of is how
much i loved this episode this was my
favorite of the season so far and there
were so many big moments in it i feel
the show just keeps getting better and
better every week and the quality of it
is constantly improving on what's come
before really brilliant entry and we
also had it announced in the week that
season 4 is coming very soon as well i'm
hyped and i'm glad we're going to be
getting more of the boys as it's such a
great series now as i promised i thought
we'd talk about the teasers that they're
giving towards but yeah full spoilers
ahead for the ending of the comics but
if you watched up until this point i
really appreciate you thank you and i'll
see you next friday now in the source
material we discover that butcher
continues his quest to wipe out all
compound beyond earth and this leads to
him tackling those that it's still
inside of namely the boys we've seen in
the show that the effects of it last way
longer than 24 hours so there is
potential that it might become something
permanent in the characters this could
lead to him trying to kill the boys come
the end of the series and in the comics
he wiped out malory chemical mother's
milk and frenchie he built a device to
kill all the soups similar to the one
that little nina had but huey managed to
stop him we learned that just in the
same way lenny held him back from going
off the deep end that huey had too and
subconsciously butcher wanted him to
defeat him the ending was pretty sad
with butcher even smiling as he died i
do think the episode really teased
towards this eventual outcome but let me
know below exactly what you think also
let me know your thoughts on the episode
and as a thank you you'll be entered
into a competition that we're running
right now where we're giving away three
copies of everything everywhere all at
once on the 15th of july all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on screen right now so that's
you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want some else to
watch then make sure you check our
theories video which will be linked on
screen right now we talk about all the
characters that could potentially kill
homelander so definitely head over there
right after this without the way thanks
for sticking through the video i've been
poor i'll see you next time take care
peace